now next this morning there is high
security in kabul as taliban leaders
meet from major summits set to shape the
future of afghanistan and there has in
fact been some breaking news uh we can
tell you about on the security front
live disguise instrument rashid who's in
kabul for us hi to you nz so tell us
what's going on
so this was a meeting that started today
of around 3 000 senior officials
of the taliban along with islamic
scholars this is a mass meeting the
biggest that the taliban has had since
2001 based here in kabul at the
polytechnic university but what we
understand in the last hour or so with
video circling on social media with
local producers and local media reports
on the ground that there were sounds of
gunfire and explosions now in the last
20 minutes or so
the taliban spokesperson has said that
there is no problem around the meeting
area several shots were fired by
security forces at a location that was
suspicious security forces filed several
shots as a suspect but there were no
other concerns it is our understanding
that the gunfire and the sounds of
explosion were around the polytechnic
university where this mass meeting
had been taking place but over the last
20 minutes or so the taliban confirming
that there are no other
concerns and there is no problem
around the meeting as i mentioned this
is an incredibly important meeting
because it's the largest ones of the
taliban gathering since 2001 and they're
here to come up with some declarations
from rules some some laws to implement
over the next few days and high on the
agenda is actually secondary school for
girls we know they rode back on their
pledge to allow all girls to go to
school when they came into power last
year and it's caused a rift not only
with the international community a lot
of the western governments condemning
their decision but also within the
taliban itself we were speaking to a
senior taliban official a few days ago
who'd actually said that they shot
themselves in the foot with that
decision and so
that set back diplomatic relations they
will be reviewing uh that that decision
and um that there are um there are
a lot of sources saying that they could
decide that girls can go back to
secondary school there's also
conversations around whether politicians
uh who were in the government prior can
come back into afghanistan that they
will be safe that they will not be
harassed by the taliban that they will
not be arrested and and prosecuted that
is on the agenda and also
a potential return to uk and u.s
embassies in kabul that will be a big
talking point but of course that's not
going to happen unless those issues on
human rights and girls education are
resolved in the next few days but the
breaking news is is that there has been
some gunfire as we understand around
where this mass meeting of around 3 000
taliban senior officials
are
currently the only statement has been
released from the taliban they say there
is no problem around the meeting shots
were fired
to suspects but there are now no other
concerns here in kabul